parlementaire
lu dans europe hebdo au parlement
européen à bruxelles
cette semaine on va parler d'immigration
comment l'europe intègre-t-elle ces
immigrés focus sur le modèle britannique
du multiculturalisme l'europe via les
yeux focaliser sur ces dizaines de
milliers de jeunes qui campent sur des
places à athènes à paris et ici à
bruxelles
après le printemps arabe y aura-t-il un
été européen
ils se sont donné rendez vous aux douze
coups de minuit place puerta del sol
main levée ils protestent en silence
indignés est déterminée à faire entendre
leur ras-le-bol de la crise et du
chômage qui frappe la moitié des moins
de 25 ans dans le pays
une fronde citoyenne spontanée et
pacifique
comme pour les révolutions arabes
c'est sur internet que tout a commencé
le 15 mai veille d'élections dans le
pays un appel à prendre la rue est
lancée sur ce site demokratia realia la
démocratie réelle maintenant message
instantanément relayé sur facebook et
twitter
grâce au web le mouvement se propage
dans toute l'espagne
la puerta del sol devient la nouvelle
place tahrir et le mouvement fait des
émules en italie en grèce en france
jusqu'en islande et qui sont donc ces
indignés des jeunes pour la plupart
étudiants salariés ou chômeurs mais
aussi des moins jeunes et même des
retraités bref les oubliés de la crise
qui en ont marre d'être pauvres et
précaires
il dénonce pêle-mêle l'injustice sociale
l'austérité les dérives du capitalisme
et la corruption des politiques après le
printemps arabe
y aura-t-il un été européen jusqu'où ira
la marche des indignés alors avec nous
sur le plateau d' europe hebdo henri
weber bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
député européen français vous êtes du
groupe socialiste ici donc au parlement
européen est ce que vous pensez qu'on va
aller vers un été européen comme il ya
eu un printemps arabe
en tous les cas on assiste à la
naissance d'une génération politique
on sait depuis 1968
que les classes d'âge peuvent être des
acteurs politiques majeurs notamment la
jeunesse puisque edgardo rappelait la
classe d'âge adolescente juive il
ce qui fait qu'une classe d'âge devient
un acteur politique générationnel c'est
qu'elle vit une expérience forte en
commun et l'expérience forte que vit la
classe d'âge actuelle dans toute
l'europe
c'est à la suite de la crise des
supprimes et des dettes souveraines la
crise économique la plus grave qu'on ait
connues depuis 1929 et dans laquelle
nous pataugeons encore on est loin dans
les deux sorties elle vit une expérience
du no future de la précarité et de
l'absence de perspectives
professionnelles vous pensez qu'il ya à
dire il y à une unité de la jeunesse
européenne on parle des espagnols des
grecs éventuellement des français il ya
quelques manifestations ici à bruxelles
est-ce qu'ils sont unis tous ces genres
entre les cas une vive des conditions
semblables se tenir la clé
le chômage des jeunes est très supérieur
au chômage moyen 1 sur 5 en droit à un
jeune sur cinq de moins de 25 ans avarie
sur les rails mais nous surveillons
d'année très nettement supérieur à la
moyenne nationale
l'entrée ans en contrat à durée
indéterminée est de plus en plus tardive
donc l'autonomie économique est de plus
en plus tardives et donc à dépendance et
vous pensez qu'il ya les ingrédients
pour ça explose nom d'une explosion
entré qu'à une certaine conception de la
démocratie va prendre corps
la démocratie c'est pas seulement le
pouvoir souverain du peuple d'élire ses
gouvernants on les chasse et la
démocratie c'est un ensemble de droits
et pas seulement seul de droits civils
et politiques mais aussi des droits
économiques et sociaux
est ce que disent les jeunes dans ces
divers pays sait où sont nos droits
économiques et sociaux
il faut que les élites que connu que nos
populations soient à même de renouer
avec une croissance forte et c'est
pourquoi le parti socialiste en france
met en avant la revendication des 300000
emplois jeunes à créer celle du tutorat
pour que les salariés expérimentés
prennent en charge un jeune et lui
apprennent le métier est tout à fait
puis alors le tout un effort 9000 sur la
formation à tous les niveaux quand il
débarque quand on écoute ses jeunes par
exemple quand on écoute ce qu'ils disent
à madrid il y avait des élections vous
le savez évidemment en espagne mais il
disait au lendemain des élections nous
de toute façon nous ne sommes
représentés par aucun politique est ce
qu ici par exemple au parlement européen
à bruxelles au coeur de l'europe
là on en discute j'ai envie de dire tous
les deux mais est ce que c'est un sujet
de préoccupation des responsables
européens est ce qu'ils sont en train de
se dire notre jeunesse
elle a un problème oui bien sûr bien sûr
c'est une préoccupation absolument
majeur maëlys finitude on peut dire une
vraie nuit l'inquiétude l'issue c'est le
retour à une croissance forte mais
durable c'est-à-dire respectueuse de
l'environnement et des intérêts des
générations futures
on ne s'en sortira pas en un problème du
chômage chronique en europe avec la
chute de la croissance ils en sont en
crise donc il faut être capable de
relancer une croissance forte durable
riche en emplois et ce à quoi nous nous
employons ici au parlement européen
alors vous vous connaissez bien j'ai
envie de dire les révoltes de jeunes à
vous avez été au coeur de mai 68 à titre
personnel vous sentez de la solidarité
avec ces jeunes qu'on voit par exemple
je me réjouis qu'il ne reste pas passifs
que ces jeunes qui sont dans la
difficulté un peu partout en europe au
lieu de ronger leur frein et de chercher
des solutions individuelles et il n'y a
pas de ceux du sur individuel se
regroupent pour réfléchir à leur
situation
poser des problèmes aux partis existants
éventuellement créer des partis nouveau
on verra
mais en tous les cas chercher des
réponses collectives à une situation de
crise qui est collective est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec le constat qui a été
fait sur cette génération de jeunes qui
ont sont à peu près trentenaires ou un
peu moins aujourd'hui on a dit 2 souvent
qu'ils étaient totalement apathique
alors c'est vrai qu'ils sont au chômage
leurs perspectives sont assez sombres et
pourtant jusqu'à présent il ne bougeait
pas vous êtes d'accord avec ça non je
crois pas qu'il soit apathique la preuve
et ils se sont mobilisés en d'autres
circonstances surtout en france mais pas
seulement
la jeunesse est sourd descendus dans la
rue d'ailleurs pour même sur la question
des retraites elle est descendue dans la
rue et pas pour penser aux siennes mais
elle s'est mobilisée contre l'injustice
donc c'est une jeunesse qui est
nullement apathique
c'est pas parce qu'elle n'est pas
violente que lé apathique
merci beaucoup henri weber d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors l'europe
vous le savez s'inquiète sur un autre
sujet c'est celui d'une grave crise
sanitaire qui concerne une bactérie
toute l'europe
évidemment se préoccupe de ce dossier je
vous propose un petit tour d'europe des
télévisions européennes
regardez la décision est tombée dans
l'après-midi les concombres espagnols
sont interdits d'importation en belgique
en effet les produits des distributeurs
espagnols c'est soupçonné d'avoir causé
une intoxication en allemagne
à l'origine de cette intoxication
bactéries qui aurait déjà tué 13
personnes en allemagne hambourg quatre
écoliers ont été infectées par la
bactérie leur établissement est resté
fermé un nombre considérable de salles
de classe doit être désinfectée la
situation est grave
en un week-end quatre femmes de 38 à 87
ans sont mortes
les chercheurs de ce laboratoire de
munster ont identifié la souche de la
bactérie qui est responsable de la mort
de plusieurs femmes juste c'est souches
ips est particulièrement résistante
maman à l'appel ainsi jans les autorités
andalous sont en train de faire des
analyses sur le lieu d'exploitation du
concombre contaminé par la bactérie
le gérant de l'entreprise you malaga
d'où proviennent les concombres
conteneur est formel pour lui ce n'est
pas la culture des concombres espagnols
qui est en cause mais le fait que le
chargement de biens combres soit tombée
est chaud le marché de hambourg là après
pour lui confirmer l'incident
depuis deux jours l'europe a demandé à
tous ses états membres de surveiller les
importations de concombres en provenance
d'espagne
la répression des fraudes indique ce
soir avoir identifié puis retirer un lot
de concombres importés du sud de
l'espagne
parallèlement le réseau de veille
sanitaire révèle avoir détecté 3 cas
d'intoxication suspect en lien avec
l'épidémie
alors comme chaque semaine dans europe
hebdo nous accueillons un correspondant
européen ici à bruxelles aujourd'hui
c'est griselda pastor bonjour vous êtes
correspondante de la radio espagnole
cadena ser quand on voit ces images là
qu'on voit que en fait l'espagne a
véritablement été montré du doigt
pendant toute une semaine en fait les
concombres espagnols ne sont pas la
cause de cette contamination
comment ça a été vécu en espagne très
mal docu depuis commencement bien sûr
parce que il ya un sentiment de profonde
injustice
donc il ya un problème sur le système
d'alerté européen et un problème sur le
deuxième problème il ya un problème sur
le système d'alerté européen qui tout de
suite avant que le préfet fini permet de
pénaliser à toute vitesse quelqu'un dans
ces cas des producteurs espagnols et la
production en général espagnol ça c'est
un problème le deuxième problème c'est
un problème institutionnel
parce que d'une certaine façon se pose
la question si j'aurais pas été
l'allemagne qui aurait lancé cette
alerte est ce que la réaction dans les
institutions aurait été la même
par exemple si ça avait été l'inversé si
ç'avait été l'espace vert prenons comme
exemple à partir du moment où un bourg
annonce que ce puits le concombre
espagnol
la commission européenne a eu besoin de
sept twitter donc entre nous 14 heures
l'après midi et 22 heures du soir pour
sortir sa déclaration et des rouies on a
noté c'est pas les concombres espagnols
sans jamais ou de l'espagne sans jamais
dire on est désolé pour les producteurs
espagnols en félicitant les aliments
pour le travail fait et les efforts
accomplis pour essayer de trouver la
cause de cette infection
on sait que les espagnols sont assez de
pro-européens enfin globalement ils sont
assez conscients de ce que l'intégration
dans l'europe a fait pour le pays est ce
que vous pensez que cette affaire de la
bactérie va changer les choses est ce
que maintenant par exemple bruxelles est
vu différemment par les citoyens
espagnols
écoutez malheureusement en espagne on a
le sentiment de l'allemagne a été
injuste on fait abstraction des travail
sur la jaunisse l'albanie contre la
commission m malheureusement c'est comme
ça mais c'est qui montre encore une fois
de plus la faiblesse institutionnelle
européenne est si lourde
même si c'est contradictoire comme image
et les six fortes cette faiblesse que
les espagnols ne retient n'aime pas que
les institutions auraient pu avoir un
rôle différent et vous ici en tant que
correspondante de cadena ser de la radio
qu'est ce que vous disiez pendant tous
ces jours qu'elles ont été la teneur de
vos de vos reportages faits de bruxelles
j'essayais d'expliquer que du point de
vue de la commission il y avait un
problème c'est que la bactérie existe et
qu'elle était dans les concombres donc
le concombre devaient être retirés et qu
il y avait rien d'autre à dire pour
l'instant c'était ça et ça c de c c'est
ce qui a généré la prise surprise quand
on a compris que c'était pas l'écart et
que jamais dans une conférence de presse
personnes avaient dit qu'elles étaient
les autres succès les autres éléments
qui doivent être analysés en allemand
est ce que vous pensez qu'il aurait
fallu aussi que les médias européens
adoptent un ton un peu plus prudent ça
c'est toujours difficile à dire
évidemment on parle de quelque chose qui
a provoqué les morts dont bon il faut
dire que dans un cas pareil demander une
certaine prudence
à partir du moment où quelqu'un de façon
officielle tandis que lacoste vient d'un
produit c'est difficilement ce difficile
donc bon je sais pas oui peut-être on
peut toujours avoir plus de retenue mais
mais mais je crois que c'est difficile
pour moi c'est encore le mans c'est tout
si on accède en tout cas l'espagne est
sous le choc de cette affaire merci
griselda pasteur d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à un autre sujet de
préoccupation en europe depuis plusieurs
mois c'est l'intégration des communautés
immigrées plusieurs dirigeants européens
ont constaté l'échec de cette
intégration en europe alors avant de
retrouver kathia gilder et son invité je
vous propose de partir à londres pour un
reportage qui est signée patrick herman
scène
la grande bretagne est une société
multiculturelle un constat qui saute aux
yeux dans les rues de londres une des
capitales les plus cosmopolites d'europe
avec 50 nationalités et plus de 300
langues
ça c'est pour la carte postale depuis
les attentats du 7 juillet 2005 qui ont
fait 56 morts et 700 blessés
quelque chose a changé les poseurs de
bombe était tout citoyen britannique et
musulmans le 11 septembre anglais a
remis en cause le modèle d'intégration
l'islam est devenu un enjeu pour les
politiques dernier en date david cameron
le premier ministre conservateur
au nom du multiculturalisme
nous avons encouragé différentes
cultures à vivre séparées nous avons
même tolérer que ces communautés parfois
bafoue nos valeurs je crois qu'il est
temps de tourner la page
brick lane street
un des quartiers les plus cosmopolite
situé à l'est de londres et à deux pas
de la city ici les propos du premier
ministre ont profondément choqué la
population
bien sûr nous avons des différences
entre communautés mais nous partageons
aussi des choses encore un sens qui
travaillons comme quand on a un objectif
celui de former une seule communauté
pour réussir à vivre ensemble dans ce
quartier symbole du melting-pot al
anglaise la population d'origine bengali
représente près de 30% des habitants
sur ce marché les femmes portant le
voile intégral ce la ne choque personne
et pour ce marchand ça fait partie du
business il ya peu de femmes musulmanes
qui portent le voile intégral c'est une
minorité
à peine 5 à 7% entre elles al'inverse
des émirats
aujourd'hui c'est le jour de la grande
prière à la mosquée de l'est de londres
une des plus importantes de la capitale
on y pratique un islam modéré ouvert et
tolérant plus de 5000 fidèles s'y
retrouvent chaque vendredi
si la question du voile intégral ne fait
pas débat outre-manche pour la
communauté musulmane
la remise en cause du multiculturalisme
est ressentie comme une stigmatisation
supplémentaire en angleterre dans
certains quartiers c'est très difficile
pour les femmes musulmanes qui portent
le voile intégral dès qu'elles sont dans
la rue elles doivent faire face à des
agressions verbales elles se sont
humiliés c'est vraiment dur l'islam ce
n'est pas le terrorisme
c'est une religion qui délivre un
message de paix les musulmans sont
devenus les victimes d'une islamophobie
ou chaque musulman est assimilé à un
terroriste ce qu'il faut chaque hommes
devraient être jugés en tant qu'individu
à quelques centaines de mètres de la
mosquée la station le gate lieux d'un
des quatre attentats en 2005
le discours est sensiblement différent
minoritaire mais bien réelle sur un
certain ressenti de la population
britannique
le problème que nous avons avec le
multiculturalisme
ce n'est pas le modèle en lui-même c'est
que les communautés vivent séparées les
unes des autres dans des vies parallèles
et jamais comme des anglais
bref est ce la fin du modèle anglais
d'intégration pour cet universitaire
français qui enseigne et vit en
grande-bretagne depuis 16 ans on en est
loin
c'est un modèle qui pour eux
marche bien puisqu'il met l'accent sur
ce qui finalement il semble et semble le
plus important pour eux c'est à dire la
tolérance et la liberté individuelle
étant entendu que temps que cette
liberté individuelle ne n'empiète pas
sur celle des autres et bien et bien
tout va bien donc pour cette raison le
port du niqab dans la rue n'est pas un
problème puisque moment c'est un choix
personnel étant que ceci ne crée pas de
problème et d'atteinte à l'ordre public
et bien il n'y a aucune raison de d'un
d'intervenir six ans après les attentats
si politiquement l'islam est devenu un
sujet récurrent du débat public pour les
citoyens de sa gracieuse majesté le
multiculturalisme est un des piliers de
la société anglaise ici la liberté
individuelle de l'exercice du culte
reste un élément fondamental du vivre
ensemble britannique
voilà retour à bruxelles nous sommes
avec jean landert bonjour je vous êtes
députée européenne sept britanniques
venaient même de londres alors on a
voulu justement comprendre la réalité de
cette société communautaire très
différente de notre modèle français
républicain qu'est ce que c'est que le
multiculturalisme finalement en grande
bretagne est ce que ça fait partie de
l'identité culturelle de votre pays je
crois que c'est mais il faut aussi dire
que il n'ya pas il n'a une seule idée de
ce qu'est ce que c'est le
multiculturalisme
quand on prend par exemple david cameron
qui parle de ça on sait bien que pour
jouer c'est s'est pas vraiment partie de
sa vie et c est pour lui il voit les
gens quand ce sont des petites boîtes
qui ne s'accroche pas et c'est pas la
réalité
donc vous dites que le
concrètement le multiculturalisme que
fustige aujourd'hui david cameron n'est
pas en crise tout va bien on peut dire
que tout va bien parce que c'est s'est
jamais comme ça mais pour plupart des
gens oui la vie passe assez bien il n'y
a pas vraiment de problème on est là on
a des voisins des pays différents
d'origines différents et ce serait
surtout à londres on a fait beaucoup de
travail à londres pour contre le racisme
pour un poids une fois plus qui me tend
les ronces dans leur aise
ça a aidé mais on ne veut pas vraiment
mais au fait que c'est plus que ça on
apprend même que depuis les attentats du
11 septembre des attentats de londres et
les choses ont un peu changé que
l'islamisme que l'islam et est
stigmatisé ce que ces cas est ce que les
positions ont changé au sein de la de la
changer mais la religion est l'islam ça
c'est vrai et ils ont principalement un
procès sans pourtant que voilées et
aussi un peu et immigration après
l'arrivée de plans de polonais par
exemple et on voit que ça aussi comme
communication chez nous c'est pas que
c'est pas toujours comme ça dans tous
les pays de l'europe
et maintenant on voit aussi que les
partis de l'extrême droite utilise un
islam plus que les questions de race
c'est vraiment une autre vocabulaire
pour dire les mêmes choses alors en
france aussi un débat important qui est
lancée sur l'intégration sur l'islam sur
la laïcité
je vous propose d'écouter
nicolas sarkozy c'était en février
dernier il s'exprime aussi sur sur cette
question de l'islam écouter ce qu'ils
disent nos compatriotes musulmans
doivent pouvoir vivre pratiquer leur
religion comme n'importe quel de vos
compatriotes juifs protestants
catholiques mais il ne peut s'agir que
d'un islam de france et non pas d'un
islam en france
alors qu'est-ce que quelle est votre
réaction à ces propose que jours qu'il
croque les hakkas à l'islam
c'est pas le cas c'est long d'être
chrétien pourrait être prêté un plan de
dénominations différentes on peut croire
même des choses différentes pour les
chrétiens et c'est un peu la même chose
pour les musulmans c'est pas une
question d'un islam de la france islam
de quoi et parce que on sait bien par
exemple si on part de zéro saoudi ça
c'est vraiment qu'une chose de très
différent dans les amants bangladesh
donc c'est m quad deux clients quand
c'est compliqué c'est plus l'hiver que
ça brûle plus généralement quel regard
portez vous sur
le modèle français le modèle
d'intégration à la française de ce que
je comprends c'est un peu si je peux
oser le dire un peu comme en turquie
qu'il n'y a qu'un seul droit chemin
d'être français moi je n'aime pas la loi
par exemple contre la voile intégral je
crois que ça c'est vraiment une vraiment
une erreur politique pour ça fait rien
vraiment pour les femmes il le semble et
je crois que si on peut être différent
mais dans le même pays et vivre ensemble
sont vraiment grands problèmes
je crois que ça c'est ce que sarkozy bhl
vraiment c'est presque un jeu politique
qui fait là mais quand même plus
généralement en europe ont l'impression
que le multiculturalisme est remis en
cause
angela merkel aussi à parler de faillite
du modèle multiculturel est ce que
l'europe de manière
général à un problème d'intégration est
ce que le modèle d'intégration européen
est en crise aujourd'hui je prends par
exemple que pour les politiciens comme
mme merkel ils n'ont jamais pratiqué à
une politique 2015
ces déclarations politiques parce que si
on regarde en allemagne par exemple il
ya une histoire de mettre les gens à
l'écart
ce sont les cocasses loi que des invités
c'est quand les gens qui vont rester
qu'ils font vraiment partie d'une
société et pour moi ce qu'il faut faire
c'est d'en voir les gens qui font partie
d'une société qui ont la possibilité
d'agir politiquement de m deux d'être
actif ou pas exactement quelle manière
il pourrait être actif être intégrés
qu'est-ce que ati gros ça veut dire
qu'on comprend toutes les heures mais
les chances d'avoir un emploi comme les
autres d'avoir une indication comme les
autres d'agir politiquement ou pas
comme tout le monde et ses 102 me semble
que d'avoir vraiment un modèle
d'intégration qui s'est échoué il n'ya
pas les choses fixe dans la société
jamais donc c'est vraiment intéressant
mais c'est pas une crise
eh bien merci jean lambert d'avoir été
notre invité et comme chaque semaine
l'europe est au bout du fil pour
répondre à vos questions concrètes vous
avez par exemple l'achat vous partez au
danemark
est ce que vous pouvez l'emmener avec
vous c'est la question de sa rade
marseille voici la réponse
boujou cela vous pouvez voyager avec
votre chat chien au furet dans tout pays
de l'union européenne mais l'animal doit
avoir un passeport européen pour animaux
de compagnie ces passeports peut être
obtenue auprès des to vétérinaire agréé
il contient les détails de la
vaccination contre la rage qui doit être
un jour
voilà un système de cette émission de
rentrée de la semaine prochaine nous
serons à strasbourg passer une très
belle semaine sur les chaînes
parlementaires
à bientôt bye